in this video I want to talk about just
a few more details a few more details
about about the hyperbolic equation the
michaelis-menten model the hyperbolic
equation and the michaelis-menten model
forgive me for my poor handwriting I
just don't want to take too long in this
video I just want to say it just a few
more things so in the last video we
talked about the hyperbolic graph right
which looked a little something like
this
good reaction velocity on the left and
we had or on the y-axis rather and we
had substrate concentration on the
x-axis and we said look something like
this right where the reaction velocity
sort of leveled off after a certain
point as far as substrate concentration
goes increasing it beyond a certain
point doesn't further increase the
velocity and that's because at a certain
point we reach v-max right that maximum
velocity up here is v-max okay and we
said at the at v-max over two we had
what was called the km right so that
substrate concentration there was the km
okay the km was the substrate
concentration at v-max over two right
and we talked about specifically what
the km was and then we mentioned the
hyperbolic equation right which was a
which was this hyperbolic equation which
we said that if you had a particular if
you wanted to find the velocity of a of
you know an enzymatic reaction and the
maddox catalyzed reaction then you would
use this equation this hyperbolic
equation right where if you had if you
knew the v-max in the km all you had to
do is plug in the substrate
concentration and you'd find the
velocity at that particular substrate
concentration now I want to go into
few more details and those details are
as follows as far as you know at what
you expect mathematically at these
different substrate concentrations so if
what's what should you expect what
should you expect when the substrate
concentration is equal to the km what we
can do is we just plug this in
mathematically and say well well we know
that we should have a V equal to v-max
over 2 so let's actually show this
mathematically so the substrate
concentration is equal to the km what we
can do is we can replace km here with
substrate concentration so we plug in
v-max right times the substrate
concentration over km plus the substrate
concentration but instead of putting km
right we're going to put in a substrate
concentration because the km is equal to
the substrate concentration so then what
we get is we get v-max times the
substrate concentration over 2 times the
substrate concentration and then the
substrate concentrations cancel and we
just have v-max over 2 so the velocity
the velocity that we should expect when
the substrate concentration is equal to
the km is v-max over 2 okay so that's
the mathematical sort of reasoning
behind it let me go further and
elaborate on a few more things what
happens if we have the substrate
concentration being much much greater
than the km right so that would be the
case where we have a substrate
concentration that's this you know far
beyond the km much much greater then if
we can we can kind of imagine that right
which you kind of imagine that as the km
being effectively equal to 0 okay it's
pretty close to zero at least relative
to the substrate concentration but it's
such an exam be such a small number
relative to the substrate concentration
well then what happens okay well we'd
have the velocity right equal to the
v-max times the substrate concentration
over if we say that the km is
essentially zero then we wouldn't
include we just save 0 plus the
substrate concentration right so we can
you know we could put that here zero
plus the substrate concentration which
is just
Vmax times the substrate concentration
over the substrate concentration those
values cancel and then we get v-max
right so what we're saying here
essentially is that at very very high
substrate concentrations we should be at
B max which is exactly the case if we
have a substrate concentration that's
right here for instance right and it's
much much greater than the km then we
would expect to be at came at the v-max
okay so hopefully that makes sense there
again this is the mathematical reasoning
okay what if the substrate concentration
is much much smaller than the km right
so in this case we can imagine the the
substrate concentration is close to zero
or effectively zero okay
so what we do here is we say that the
velocity will be equal to the v-max
times now I'm still going to include the
substrate concentration here because I
can't want to multiply v-max
times zero but it's the subject
concentration is a very small number
it's effectively zero but down here what
we're going to have is we have the v-max
over the km plus zero right which is
just V Max over km times the substrate
concentration so what does this mean
here right what is this what's going on
here that essentially what we can
conclude is that the velocity is
proportional to the substrate constitute
not to five to the substrate
concentration okay so we should have a
linear relationship that there'll be a
direct relationship between the
substrate concentration and V because V
Max and km are both constant numbers
right so they're not going to be
changing the only thing that could
change here is the substrate
concentration so if we increase the
substrate concentration then we would
expect the velocity to increase you know
in a directly proportional way so that's
it's implied here and that makes sense
too right if we have a much if we have a
very small concentration of substrate
here much less than the km we would
expect there to be a linear relationship
a direct relationship so I hope those
few details helped you understand the
material a little bit better in case
you're interested but that's about it
thanks for watching